moi dis-moi que je suis bien cap c'est
bon il y a pas de problème le look c'est
l'allure mélangé à une philosophie de
une des rares choses qui restent je
crois en ce moment pour pouvoir montrer
ce qu'on pense sans avoir peur de ce
qu'on est vraiment il y a plusieurs
choses qui qui font qu'une personne
s'habille d'une telle ou telle maîtresse
je suis la musique que j'écoute c'est
très varié il y a pas franchement un
look il y a plusieurs look ceci dit au
niveau de du look on peut dire que que
tout ce qui est rap à base de rap c'est
vraiment dégagé quoi ceci dit il y a un
métissage qui se fait en Europe aussi
avec un petit peu la mode européenne
anglaise anglaise et plus ou moins
française c'est plutôt le côté flip et
cetera que les Américains ne connaissent
pas je pense que déjà les jeunes ont
envie de délirer quoi ils ont envie de
couleurs ils ont envie de se sentir bien
dans leur peau c'est
assez mieux parce qu'on redécouvre des
des périodes qu'on a pas connu et on a
l'impression de les connaître à travers
à travers tout ce qu'on doit autour de
nous j'ai un look de vieux quand voilà